we've got breaking news to report we are  just learning legendary broadcaster  larry king has died  the announcement was made moments ago on  king's twitter page  king was a fixture on television radio  and for decades hosting an interview  show on cnn  he recently was hospitalized for  symptoms related to covet 19 in los  angeles  larry king was 87 years old we knew he  was hospitalized and then we thought  getting a little bit better  they said but now obviously we get this  tough news  this morning and someone that i think we  all learn from and so many people learn  watching him over those decades and how  he could interview everyone  yeah in ways that and then when you one  thing you learned from him is the way he  asked those questions yeah  tight and concise yeah didn't waste a  lot of words so  live and live think about that and live  that is absolutely right kept insisting  on answers  yes he did